作詞・作曲 李宗盛 李宗盛
Hey there and welcome to Copenhagen-Castrop Airport for another trip report.
It's 7am here and I've just arrived on an overnight flight from Montreal with Air Canada.
Here in Copenhagen I have a connection time of 70 minutes before I catch a 35 minute flight with SAS up to Gothenburg
on board one of their ATR-72600s that's operated by XFLY.
但我第一次航空的航空是在空中,所以我必須有問題在這交通
Copenhagen Airport是分了兩次,T2和T3,
一共有一個公共駕駛的航空間,而是一層的航空間
空間駛的航空間是分了A,B,C,D,E,F,Piers
PiersC, where I arrived today,用了主機外的航空間
我到達到PierC,我從來就有一個很快的5分鐘的步驟到我的門口上的E Pier
我的飛行是用GateE7的旅程,
這是一個相機的門口,所以我們會到達到飛行的航空
開始在7.50am,20分前離
SAS的飛行動並在這次的飛行動,
而在这次选择, Groups A and B是主要是主要的,
包括SAS Euro Bonus Gold and Diamond members,
Star Alliance Gold members,
和选择上一个SAS Plus ticket。
Groups D and E是主要选择上一个SAS Go Smart,
或 Go Light Fair,
或是主要的,
而是主要选择上一个SAS Go Light Fair,
或是主要选择上一个SAS Go Light Fair,
在这次选择上,
我们的选择上一个Bus今天,
groups don't really mean a whole lot.
The ride over to our aircraft was only about 5 minutes,
where we finally got our first look at the plane for today's flight.
This short flight between Denmark and Sweden will be onboard this 10.5 year old ATR72-600
that started its life in December 2012 flying around India for Jet Airways,
before being transferred to Nordica in December 2019,
where it now operates under the XFLY brand.
SAS has seven of this aircraft type in their fleet,
all operated under a lease agreement by XFLY.
First thoughts before we step inside,
this aircraft looks shockingly clean,
like it's just rolled off the factory floor.
Heading inside, the same comment applies here,
where it's super clean and fresh feeling. The interior design is simple and not terribly colourful, but I can't say I expected more from a Scandinavian airline. The seats have a great design,整個感覺。內容是很簡單,並不太顏色,但我還不想說我還想過更多的船艦。這座位有黑色的布,
沒有預測的頭部,
並且很輕的,不太修理。
但這座位是非常好,
這座位是一種全都的,
並且有70架座位置。
我已經是2A的座位,
which is a window seat in the second row of the cabin.
As you likely noticed, we boarded the aircraft from the rear,
as that's the only boarding door on board.
The front of the aircraft houses the cargo hold,
in between where I'm sitting and the cockpit.
Settling into my seat, first thoughts are that it's quite firm,
but the whole seat area is crazy clean and well kept.
Taking a look around my seat, the legroom is pretty tight,
在我的座位,我只有几个小时的屁股,
在我的座位,有个座位置的座位置
在我的座位置的中间,
不让它很容易处理的东西,
不然在我的座位置的座位置上,
不过在这样的小型的座位置,
在这些座位置的座位置是可以够的充满的充满,
甚至买了衣服的套位置,
在这里的座位置上,
在上面有一個保持的東西,
看到我們有一個保持的東西,
有一個保持的保持,
這個保持卡,
以及一個保持卡,
在購物中,我們有一個飲食,
包括飲食,
飲食,
也在在上面的托坐,有一個小拋時刻,
有小拋後在托坐水平線上的背景。
下的桜電鍵置,這裡面有一個放置可貼置,
一個架固定的操作可以輯入它的耳機器,
這邊有座標紙幅部位置的空間,
會有一個木頭部位置的部件。
下的土壤層,這裡面有一個面子物,
履層層層層層層層層層層層層層層層層。
Unfortunately, there is no in-seat power available at these seats with no USB or AC charging outlets.
Looking at the overhead panel above the seat, we have a personal reading light for each seat, along with a personal adjustable air vent.
By far the best feature of seat 2A, the great view of this propeller engine.
大概45分鐘
下降,它要是停止,
它要停止,它要停止,
我們請你停止停止,
它在整個排列
在開始五分鐘後,
我們是有40分鐘的停止,
前往我們開始車子上車,
到駕駛的路上,好停止
中文字幕志愿者 李宗盛
Climbing away from Copenhagen, our expected flight time to Gothenburg is just 35 minutes.
The weather in both Copenhagen and Gothenburg today is cloudy with some rain, but I've
still got some nice views of the Danish countryside down below.
整個空間的空間
在前面的船上,有一船的空間是一船上的船上
這邊的空間是很小的,但這不太大用的船上來的船上
他們有温泡和泡沫,而且泡沫是供應的也
這不可能不太有意義,但相似的相似,像是比較普通的,
不像是比較普通的,不像泡沫和泡沫在泡沫
我回到我的座位,他們會在家裡的船部工作了一道,
在美国的飞行中,只有酒和酒和酒都可以购买的,
所有其他东西需要购买的东西。
除了我们的时间,我们已经在国家离开枪,
我们也会购买水,自由转换。
在一旦,我们也有更多的声音和声音和声音
比特币的更多一位在摩擦,但它是要不施的駕駛。
在下一次距離的距離下,是一些更多的比特币。
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
中文字幕志愿者 李宗盛
有些国家,没有公司接触到国家,
所以我向上向公司连接到公司的公司。
Landvetter Airport is located 20km southeast of the city center and is the second largest airport in Sweden.
It's connected to Gothenburg by several shuttle services, one of which is Fliggbussarna that I'll be using today.
The cost to travel from the airport to the Nils Eriksson Terminal downtown is 129krona, or about 12USD.
There's a ticket machine in the baggage claim area, or you can buy them online.
中文字幕志愿者 杨栋梁
I hope you enjoyed it.
I was pleasantly surprised by SAS's ATR-72s, which have a super clean and modern feeling
cabin.
The onboard service was limited, but for such a short flight you can't expect much more.
The transfer process in Copenhagen from an Air Canada to an SAS flight was super simple,
despite the delay, this was overall a quick and easy journey.